they reinstated Amber Heard to play
[__] Shamu or whatever the goddamn
name is I don't know the [__] stupid
Aquaman shits you know
what's his name Enrique Obama what's his
[__] name the [__] guy who plays
it
Jason Momoa Enrique Obama
[Laughter]
's name dude Enrique Obama
um Jason Momoa dude anyway uh she's
gonna be in the in the Aquaman [__]
too many whatever the [__] new one is
Aquaman 4. however many you know what
you could tell me that there's two
Aquaman's and you could be like there's
11 Aquaman's and I would have the same
reaction I'd be like yeah probably I
don't know I don't have a [__] clue
but she's gonna be back as Aqua woman or
whatever the [__] Shira I don't know
whatever the Hell she's gonna be flipper
and um
you know
that's crazy that is so crazy to me by
the way she should be oh oh Cyrus or
whatever the [__] her name is right
I don't give a [__] but it is crazy that
they will just reinstate a woman
and if it's a dude they're [__] ow
dude they're out
they're out
a guy could like bump into a lady and
he's done forever by the way and when a
chick is like lying about the [__]
this world is mad dude and then I love
how people are like fine they're not
getting my fifteen dollars like who
gives a [__] cope I dude everybody does
everything
you know she's gonna be [__] who
she's gonna be she's obviously terrible
she's a terrible person because of all
the [__] but also we don't even
really know what happened who the [__]
knows
who the relationship was probably toxic
who the [__] knows but
um she's back she's back as the [__]
lady in Aquaman and uh
that's what's up
so I guess they're going to cut me back
into [__] Army the dead now
um
release the Delia cut dude
release the Delia caught my baby crazy
[Music]
crazy congratulations